بعد الزلزال قتل بفيضانات المدمره اجتاحت
جنوب تركيا
خبير اسرائيلي يحذر موعد الزلزال الكبير
يقترب
الكشف عن ممتلكات سرقها اللصوص من فيلا
محمد صلاح
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد نحو اربعين يوما على وقوع زلزال
المدمر استفاق سكان جنوب تركيا على
فيضانات عارمه اودت بحياه 13 شخصا على
الاقل في حصيله اوليه وسيل الام المحليه
افادتها بان السلطات تخشى من احتمال
ارتفاع عدد القتلى نتيجه الهطول الغزير
للامطار وغير العادي كذلك في عدد من
ولايات الجنوب التركيه فيما تداول رواد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي صورا وفيديوهات
للسيول الناتجه عن الامطار وهي تجرف
السيارات وكل ما تجده امامها من ممتلكات
وسط استمرار عمليات البحث عن عشرات
المفقودين
ونبقى في الاخبار المتحلقه بالكوارث
الطبيعيه اذ حذر خبير اسرائيلي كبير من
عدم قدره الحكومه والسلطات المحليه على
الاستعداد للزلزال الكبير المنتظر ان يضرب
المنطقه في الاشهر المقبله الخبير واسمه
متنياهو اوضح في تقرير له انه رغم
التحذيرات السابقه فان وزاره الاعمار
والاسكان الاسرائيليه لم تكمل دمج نحو
1100 مبنى تتطلب تدخل فوريا على وجه
التحديد في المدن الاكثر عرضه لخطر
الزلزال خوفا من انهيارها مشيرا الى ان
اسرائيل تقع بالقرب من الشق السوري
الافريقي وبالتالي فان خطر حدوث زلزال
كبير يزداد كل عام على حد قوله
والى مصر هذه المره حيث نجحت الاجهزه
الامنيه في القبض على مرتكبي واقعه سرقه
فيلا اللاعب محمد صلاح في احد التجمعات
السكنيه بالقاهره الجديده واعاده
المسروقات السلطات اوضحت في بيان لها ان
مرتكبي هذه الواقعه هما شخصان احدهما سبق
له ان عمل كفرد امن بالمجمع السكني المشار
اليه ويقيمان بمحافظه الاسماعيليه مشيره
الى انهما اعترف بارتكاب الواقعه بتاريخ
الثاني عشر من مارس الجاري فيما تم ضبط
المسروقات كافه وعدد من الاحذيه الرياضيه
ومداريه فضيه وقطعه من الكريستال وعدد من
اجهزه الاستقبال التلفزيوني اي الرسيفرز
في علامات تكنولوجيا كشفت شركه جوجل
مجموعه من ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي
لخدماتها للبريد الالكتروني والبرمجيات
التعاونيه والسحابيه ضمن خطه اعتبرت
منافسه لبرنامج الشهير الشركه الامريكيه
اوضحت ان الادوات الجديده ستكون قادره على
تلخيص موضوعات الرسائل في خدمه جيميل
وصياغه عروض بنظام الشرائح وتخصيص التواصل
مع العملاء وتدوين ملاحظات الاجتماعات
مشيره الى انها اطلقت وصف العصا السحريه
على برنامجها الشهير جوجل دوكس الذي يمكنه
صياغه مدونه تسويقيه او خطه تدريب او غير
ذلك من النصوص ثم مراجعه اسلوبه